Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay perfect Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Well hi everybody let's get started, then Thank you so much for joining us today welcome to the RStudio enterprise Community meetup,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And Rachel if I haven't had a chance to meet yet i'm calling in from Boston actually at the RStudio office today, but if you just join now feel free to introduce yourself to the chat window and say hello, maybe where you're calling in from,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): like to let everybody know up front, you can use the more button in the zoom bar below to turn on live transcription if you wish,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But just to go through a brief agenda for today's meetup so happy to have you all here we'll go through some short introductions of the meetup group,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And we'll have Viola here presenting, on her experience optimizing shiny for enterprise grade ass and will also have lots of time for questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Very left side, we can also ask questions during the middle of the presentation to but we'll have lots of time at the end as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But for anybody who's joining this group, for the first time, this is a friendly and open meetup environment and i'm sure everybody's heard this spiel,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): a bunch before but for teams to share the work they're doing within their organizations teach lessons learn network with each other and really just allow us all to learn from each other, so thank you all for making this a welcoming community,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): We really want to create a space where everybody can participate, and we can hear from everyone,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I always love to reiterate that we really love to hear from everyone, no matter your experience or the industry that you worked in as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Just a quick reminder that this session will be recorded and share to YouTube for anyone who missed it or, if you want to go back and check it out again,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So for questions you can also use the slider link which i'll put in the chat in just a moment,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So with that you can ask questions anonymously to if you don't want to be part of the recording or you can put your name there and we can call on you to jump in the conversation, which is always fun to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): What was all of that Thank you all so much for joining and so excited to turn it over to you Bella and I will mute myself here and turn it over to,
Veerle van Leemput: Okay hi welcome everybody nice to see you all i'm just closing down this presentation and,
Veerle van Leemput: move on to mine,
Veerle van Leemput: I can,
Veerle van Leemput: All right, good to see you all today we're going to talk about optimizing shiny for enterprise grade applications and what exactly will be,
Veerle van Leemput: I will tell you all about in a couple of minutes, and so, what are we going to talk about today,
Veerle van Leemput: So first i'll give her a little bit of introductions that you know we started to you and also a bit about the companies that you have a little bit of background on the kinds of applications that are making,
Veerle van Leemput: Then i'm going to dig into the content and we'll start with what happens before you start coding then we're going to the coding part So how do you write code for an enterprise grade application,
Veerle van Leemput: And then we'll talk about infrastructure and some tips and tricks on how to optimize shiny then we go over how to test your application and the last part will be about monitoring your status of the application and usage,
Veerle van Leemput: So first i'll start by introducing myself,
Veerle van Leemput: My name is farrah I a data scientist, I graduated as a data scientist in 2015 already in the Netherlands,
Veerle van Leemput: And that's also where i'm calling in from today, I did a masters of data, science and after that I started working as a data scientists at,
Veerle van Leemput: Some companies started off with an energy company then ended up in pharmaceutical industry that Dr readies,
Veerle van Leemput: And, at a certain point in time, I was like I want to start my own business, I,
Veerle van Leemput: have so many ideas, and I want to do things my own way, so I finally found a typewriter which was data science consultancy firm and during,
Veerle van Leemput: All my nice assignments there, I met my current business partner Greg meals with who I now run analytic health and i'm managing director and head of data science there,
Veerle van Leemput: And i'm a programmer I love programming are I build Shiny applications, and besides that i'm also doing a bit of javascript building applications in few and note,
Veerle van Leemput: So bit more a bit more background about the company analytic health, who are we,
Veerle van Leemput: At health we develop tools and applications for the UK healthcare sector we try to accelerate innovation in healthcare, by giving companies the tools they need,
Veerle van Leemput: to access data and to get information from the data and in order to do that, we have two applications, the first one is from the analytics and the second one is for me cloud data,
Veerle van Leemput: For latency is a shiny application, as well as farm club data and with family to data, we are also giving access to a plumber API so we do lots of stuff in our we already have core team of three people it's myself my business partner Greg mills and our head of operations Ghana,
Veerle van Leemput: and
Veerle van Leemput: To just start talking about enterprise grade Apps I want to take you into what that exactly is because an enterprise grade APP can mean many things for many of us, and most of the people,
Veerle van Leemput: Who hear enterprise grade think about our, this is an APP server thousands thousands of users with lots of servers behind it, they think big,
Veerle van Leemput: And while that might be true for an enterprise grade APP it's not the only thing that defines an enterprise grade Apps, so this is my view on what it actually means,
Veerle van Leemput: And what it means to us so, for example, the applications that we are giving access to our subscription base and they are for the B2B market, that means that people,
Veerle van Leemput: pay for them it's not an open source APP, which also means that if you say you're offering your APP true subscriptions that you need to have some kind of access control and extra data security,
Veerle van Leemput: Sometimes people or companies also provide their own data to us, which means that we need to have a high level of data security and,
Veerle van Leemput: Because people and businesses rely upon our applications to make decisions on a daily basis, we need to have high availability speeds,
Veerle van Leemput: And there needs to be data validation so the data that we're using is healthcare data from the UK and that can mean that we have information about,
Veerle van Leemput: The prescriptions that have been written what prices are of medicines, what the career and shortages are in the UK, etc, and, obviously, if you have this information, this information needs to be correct, so there are high data validation marks,
Veerle van Leemput: On top of that what I think distinguishes like a hobby shiny APP from an enterprise grade is an outstanding user experience,
Veerle van Leemput: Which means that you need to put in considerable thoughts on how the APP behaves what it looks like and what the overall feeling, as if the application,
Veerle van Leemput: And an extra thing that comes with an enterprise grade APP is support, meaning that if people have questions,
Veerle van Leemput: They can come to you immediately and that you provide this high level of support for your application so again enterprise grade, in my opinion, has nothing to do with the number of users can be thousands of users can be 10s of users can be 5100 doesn't really matter,
Veerle van Leemput: What qualifies for me as an enterprise grade areas that you put in considerable todd's on the availability on the APP and the experience when people are using your application,
Veerle van Leemput: And in fact I also want to say that an enterprise shiny F shouldn't actually feel as shiny as,
Veerle van Leemput: We sometimes get that comments from people were seeing our effort, the first time in our shining developers, they say, oh this doesn't look like shiny up but,
Veerle van Leemput: Like I love shiny and i'm i'm here to promote shine definitely and but people shouldn't see with what software, the APP was made it needs to look like a good good functioning as high quality,
Veerle van Leemput: So I see that as a compliment, so the software behind it shouldn't really matter and it's the outcome doesn't matter if you've escaped,
Veerle van Leemput: So today i'm giving you kind of a sneak peek on how we manage things and, as I said, we have two applications, and I will take you along with one of our applications which is farming cloud data I will, during my presentation reference this as a couple of times,
Veerle van Leemput: To just give you examples on how we do things with this certain APP and how it works and what the infrastructure is etc,
Veerle van Leemput: So a bit more background about application, the application is kind of the data marketplace for the UK,
Veerle van Leemput: You go into the APP you choose a data set that you're interested in you search for your active ingredients or for your medicine brands that you're looking off there, and you can download that data,
Veerle van Leemput: it's not that complicated at, meaning that our our NUTS machine learning models have name or the dark or not complicated grass or something but,
Veerle van Leemput: The APP is all about giving you an easy user interface to access all the data that you need to make your decisions,
Veerle van Leemput: Then there are a couple of Nice features there like you can add your own favorites and you can monitor your usage of the APP,
Veerle van Leemput: Because behind this APP is a Plumber API and the Plumber API and our subscription based model works with a number of requests, meaning that people have plan,
Veerle van Leemput: A subscription plan and that's kind of determines how many requests, they can make so in the Web interface, they can also see how many requests they already have made and how many there are still left in the month,
Veerle van Leemput: And you can fully customize the outcome of data set, meaning that you can change calm orders that you can,
Veerle van Leemput: Change settings the number of months, you want to repeat etc, etc, and you simply download that to an x bar so that's a bit of background of the APP that I will be referencing a couple of times date,
Veerle van Leemput: So,
Veerle van Leemput: let's first start, not by going into the code if needed me but, first with the very important and overlooked thing and do you I first principle or user experience and Judas gradients,
Veerle van Leemput: Because one does not simply succeed without plan and and often, especially if there are a lot of data scientists here today,
Veerle van Leemput: We think, well, I need to build an application and let's code,
Veerle van Leemput: But what we often forget is that we first need to think very carefully about what the APP is being used for how people are going to use it what it needs to look like where the burdens need to be etc, and this,
Veerle van Leemput: is often overlooked part of building an application, especially if you're coming from an analyst backgrounds data scientists whatsoever,
Veerle van Leemput: And this is not only true for sharing application by waivers for any application you develop so put some considerable thought into how the application is going to work,
Veerle van Leemput: And we kind of going back to my own experience at the beginning, we were also exactly like that Okay, we need to build this feature we're going to build it immediately went into the code,
Veerle van Leemput: And while the dog does lead to problems, because as soon as you are going to deploy your application in your user starts seeing defeated and it's like,
Veerle van Leemput: Oh yeah maybe it wasn't working out as we talked in the beginning, so these are all things you want to know prompt and ux designers can help you with that,
Veerle van Leemput: Perfectly because they exactly know how things should work and then you can see it before you actually start,
Veerle van Leemput: And Obviously there are shiny ways to make this kind of a prototype and one shiny way, I want to highlight is the shiny Epsom package,
Veerle van Leemput: With the shiny have some backwards, you can make this prototype a shiny yourself, and while this does mean that you start kind of with the code, it is a bit different because here you,
Veerle van Leemput: can put in place orders in your user interface,
Veerle van Leemput: Meaning that you can very easily set up an APP and just say Okay, I want to hear it table or a plot and some text and a button and Eva kind of played around with the user interface first before you actually start writing the server code,
Veerle van Leemput: So obviously the shiny Epsom package makes a reference to day lauren if some dummy text,
Veerle van Leemput: it's very easy to use, and I would definitely recommend it if you're looking for a quick way to prototype your applications,
Veerle van Leemput: So once you've done that you've kind of know what your APP is going,
Veerle van Leemput: To be about what's going to look like what it should do,
Veerle van Leemput: You go into the code and that's the interesting part but to build enterprise grade applications, you also need to put some considerable thought into how you're going to manage that code and how,
Veerle van Leemput: you're going to build your application to scale it, and this is something that we have learned over the years as well,
Veerle van Leemput: we're a startup company we basically started with an APP and then that grew and built and more customers came on it, so we learned over the years, it is very important to if you have this message APP that can do a lot of stuff and that grows over time, that your code is maintainable,
Gustavo Pittaluga: And then you can work with it,
Veerle van Leemput: So how do you exactly make maintainable code because there's kind of a magic thing,
Veerle van Leemput: And these are principles that are well, not necessarily for shiny bits for,
Veerle van Leemput: Any APP that you're developing at any software,
Veerle van Leemput: So affected maintainable code and, as I said, it's not necessarily for showing us for any APP you develop in any framework um but it's important that you write code which is easy to understand and debug,
Veerle van Leemput: Meaning that you think about coding style commenting your code keep it stupid simple the kiss principle,
Veerle van Leemput: So that is always easy to understand, you can choose to ride really complex code, but that honestly never helped us, because if you developed something very complex with a very complex piece of code and then look at it, a couple of months later you're like,
Veerle van Leemput: I didn't know what was actually happening here so magic and it does give me the inside out which you have no clue,
Veerle van Leemput: what's actually going on there anymore so keep it simple and we're also talking about maintainable code we're looking for an easy to modify and enhance code, meaning that don't repeat yourself or dry principal,
Veerle van Leemput: Meaning that if you need to make a change to your code because let's say in our APP we're going to add another data set and obviously we don't want to do,
Veerle van Leemput: Everything again we don't have to repeat our code if we need to make changes need to happen fast, because we want to have new features out fast,
Veerle van Leemput: So build your code like that you can easily modify it I going to talk a bit more about that later on and what you can actually use and what we use to kind of don't repeat ourselves,
Veerle van Leemput: Also separation whiskey, and I remember when I started working as data scientists that Dr bredesen had to build my first shot yeah,
Veerle van Leemput: And I was super proud of the APP because it had like i'll note 3000 lines of code in one script which was evidence are, and I was like whoa, this is a really cool APP so many lines of code and honestly I didn't know what I knew now, obviously,
Veerle van Leemput: Because separation splitting your code up into small easily consumable parts is essential that APP that I built,
Veerle van Leemput: In the early days and three those lines of code not maintainable at all if I needed to find something it could take me minutes or maybe half an hour to actually search through code and,
Veerle van Leemput: Make it all work, so what we do now and then the other girls is we separate basically every separate piece of functionality into separate scripts so that is,
Veerle van Leemput: Also in separate directories, meaning that if we need to find something or specific piece that does this or death, that we can easily find it,
Veerle van Leemput: And also, we need to have code it's easy to test and there comes the ultimate unit tests in place, if you have separated your code in like these terms it's also easy to test only that script for desired outcome,
Veerle van Leemput: And also talk a little bit more about that later when i'm talking about how to function is your code,
Veerle van Leemput: alright,
Veerle van Leemput: So maintainable code that's one thing and then, how are you going to organize your shiny APP and how are we doing that,
Veerle van Leemput: And we have one way, you can do is go to them and the Almighty modules and everybody talks about modules, especially when you are,
Veerle van Leemput: Talking about building enterprise Apps or building Apps for production or as soon as you come into the territory of more as far as shiny Apps then there's no way to go around modules and,
Veerle van Leemput: golem is a package that based golden as a package that actually helps you to build your shiny application as a package,
Veerle van Leemput: Good okay so um hopefully we're getting rid of the spammers i'm back to Golan and much more fun and then reading all those messages from those annoying people and,
Veerle van Leemput: So golem is basically a framework for building your prediction great shiny application, it helps you to structure your code to organize it,
Veerle van Leemput: And to basically be able to make your shiny APP as an art package, if you have any experience with building our packages, it seems very familiar to you,
Veerle van Leemput: because all the other things that are used to have making changes in your package are also here as well, so it's super easy to documents super easy to test so coming back to how to build maintainable code, make sure that you can test it,
Veerle van Leemput: goes and kind of facilities that and, obviously, because if you can package, it, you can also easily share it so that's also a great advantage, and it makes use of shiny modules,
Veerle van Leemput: And so you hear a lot about modules but there's also another way that you can kind of manage or make maintainable code,
Veerle van Leemput: And, and that is functioning I don't know if this is an actual word,
Veerle van Leemput: But what I mean with functional using your honor code is basically that you build your code up as functions and this helps you to don't repeat yourself, because if you are,
Veerle van Leemput: Making functions, I would have several servers grapes or ui parts and then you can easily use those functions in other parts of the application so coming back to my APP from cloud data or our APP I should say sorry,
Veerle van Leemput: Finally, cloud data and we what we do, there is, we provide access to different data sets so let's say we have 10 data sets,
Veerle van Leemput: And for those 10 data sets you can kind of request active ingredients and brands and then you can download data every step that's in that APP,
Veerle van Leemput: does look kind of the same So what we did here, instead of using modules for variety of reasons, we chose to function is the code, meaning that if we now need to make an adjustment to let's say the download button, we can very easily do so by just changing that function and branches are,
Veerle van Leemput: fundamental unit of affection in our use functions all the time and our is built around functions,
Veerle van Leemput: So it's very helpful to do that at least like that and to help you to,
Veerle van Leemput: Make your Apps capable, so what french's don't do is address namespace and prominent because there is one more juice do,
Veerle van Leemput: So when you're using functions, you still need to make sure yourself that's none of the input and output names or ids,
Veerle van Leemput: Have a conflict with each other, because in a shiny APP you can use the same ideas for inputs, for the same ideas for outfits because then it will just not work, so that is one downside of using functions and,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah, as I said to you can use more rules because they add this one extra level of abstraction and taking care of the namespace and problem but functions will already get you,
Veerle van Leemput: Well, good as a good start that's another thing another framework that I want to highlight today, and if you know me already, then you might have seen this but it's about a new package rhino,
Veerle van Leemput: rhino is developed by epsilon and it's also a framework that kind of promises to help you build enterprise level shiny applications, so it kind of,
Veerle van Leemput: is similar to go to birth something different, what rhino does, I think it was only released couple of weeks ago with rhino does is it helps you to have this kind of framework around building your shiny APP,
Veerle van Leemput: and helping you with all kinds of best practices and giving you a development tool, so it provides you with the basic structure of a project, it provides you with a folder structure,
Veerle van Leemput: files kind of the same as when you're using golden and it also provides tools to work with javascript to end software accountable,
Veerle van Leemput: And so, this one uses box to marginalize code meaning what box does and box basically makes our files in portable as kind of modules,
Veerle van Leemput: Meaning get you can just write in our script and then can importance using box and then it works kind of the same as a module so it's a bit different than the shiny moves work and it's definitely an interesting concept so it's actually also little bit similar to,
Veerle van Leemput: chopping up like your big all episodes are scripts into multiple our scripts and then importing them in another way box kind of take care of that and more clever way certainly to don't repeat yourself,
Veerle van Leemput: Definitely working and the other thing now is okay you've built your code, you have Nice,
Veerle van Leemput: Nice code nicely structure it's maintainable you have a build your,
Veerle van Leemput: Your cost structure of your APP using either golden functions rhino whatever there is,
Veerle van Leemput: Then so here's a question how you're going to bring that to your users you're going to use it, so a little bit about infrastructure and how we do that and,
Veerle van Leemput: Obviously there are thousands of ways, you can do it i'm not saying that the way we did it just like the the most ultimate way to do it, but for us it's worked very well,
Veerle van Leemput: So these are my experiences and our setup,
Veerle van Leemput: And this is our infrastructure so i've kind of simplified it here, then how it is in real world, obviously, but our broad infrastructure, you can be on shiny looks like this,
Veerle van Leemput: Like first we get our data somewhere and we get data from the NHS the National Health Service in the UK,
Veerle van Leemput: Then we do some stuff in our to transform it to validate that etc, then we send it somewhere to be stored and we use bins and databases for that,
Veerle van Leemput: And if you're not familiar with bins would definitely read up about this is just a nice way to store any of our objects,
Veerle van Leemput: And once we ever data somewhere, then we build tools around the data, as I said, we have api's using plumber, we have shiny applications, but we also do our Martha reports, and you will afford,
Veerle van Leemput: Using the student and then we deploy and we use RStudio connect for that,
Veerle van Leemput: So our api's and our shiny Apps are deployed in RStudio connect and are accessed from our customers outside of organization you don't hear it as a lot with RStudio connected people actually do that,
Veerle van Leemput: Would you can really nicely do that because you can also add your own branding to connect meaning,
Veerle van Leemput: That it's also perfectly usable for outside customers if they want to access your application in a safe way because, as I said, that's important for us that there is some access control, so it can have a login mechanism and RStudio connects really takes care of fits very well,
Veerle van Leemput: So, then, we basically have our email our extract transform and load and we have our Apps we have deployed and and, obviously, our ground that is,
Veerle van Leemput: Monitoring, we need to make sure that every step of this process is being taken care of version control meaning,
Veerle van Leemput: that we need to have, for example, our API,
Veerle van Leemput: and customers are directly able to access data via the API and can use the API in their own pipelines dashboards database, etc,
Veerle van Leemput: So it's very important to have a version control on there, because if you release a new version and have breaking changes, what if the pipeline of the customer depends on that,
Veerle van Leemput: So there's this whole version control system around our infrastructure and then we also have a logging part which i'm not going to go into detail about, but we just make sure that we know what's happening in every step of this process,
Veerle van Leemput: And then, if we zoom in a bit more to our infrastructure, when it comes to our applications on connect,
Veerle van Leemput: And we have a shiny up which I showed you find the cloud data and actually the server part of the shiny, it is not that interesting,
Veerle van Leemput: Because what the shiny APP does is it's making requests to the plumber API so basically our backend is being written as an API implemented,
Veerle van Leemput: And this is not any different from, for example, writing a few applications or applications in javascript because they're you often have front end and back end completely separate it's shiny brings them together but,
Veerle van Leemput: In this case we kind of chose to also separated here, so we have an API that's fetches the data from a database in our case databases and azure and the plumber API and then does some processing to retrieve the correct data, whatever was requested and sends it back to the application,
Veerle van Leemput: The application,
Veerle van Leemput: server part is then only about Okay, make a request and we're done with it,
Veerle van Leemput: The other thing that the shiny application does is making use of things,
Veerle van Leemput: So, as I briefly mentioned things our way where you can store your our objects is basically you could kind of compare it to a database it's not the same, but it's a place where you store are related stuff, for example, data tables,
Veerle van Leemput: Models objects, whatever you want really you can pin it and then you can use these things to kind of source your data into your application,
Veerle van Leemput: So the shiny APP, the only thing that's in the server parts is actually making requests to another EP,
Veerle van Leemput: or another API making a request to fetch some data, for example, what needs to be displayed in the pickers So what are the choices which active ingredients can people select which brands can people select etc,
Veerle van Leemput: And the most of those shiny the code is actually the front end and that's all being fictionalized so basically we have like couple of things for our whole user interface that provides kind of 10 steps pretend data sets and the dashboard and the favorites step, etc,
Veerle van Leemput: So it is deployed on RStudio connect we only have one server available that's kind of serves RStudio connect it's a it's a good server and fits our needs, obviously, if you have a very large audience of let's say thousands of users, you might want to look into,
Veerle van Leemput: Putting multiple servers and then kind of load balancing across these servers which are soo connects also capable we we just have one, and what we kind of do,
Veerle van Leemput: To make sure that our Apps are accessible and false is, we have always a couple of our processes running at minimum to serve these Apps,
Veerle van Leemput: For example, for the Bloomberg API we have five process is always running effort shine yet also five,
Veerle van Leemput: Meaning that there are 10 processes our processes always running to server application so that people can quickly get access to the application and do whatever they want there,
Veerle van Leemput: And I will come back to that a little bit about this process configuration and how these minimum number of processes work,
Veerle van Leemput: But this is kind of our base infrastructure, if I really simplify it,
Veerle van Leemput: And I can also give you that as as the biggest dip we've seen a lot of benefits which using an API blumberg API instead of doing everything in that one session,
Veerle van Leemput: In the shiny application itself so kind of we separated it that makes it one more maintainable and to foster as well, because we can kind of spread or load between what the APP is doing on the front end versus what is happening in the back end and we can also do those things in parallel,
Veerle van Leemput: As I said, this is just one way how we do it they're obviously a bunch of alternatives i'm not going into too much detail about it, but just so you know, there are multiple solutions to to achieve,
Veerle van Leemput: Deployment of your application for for an enterprise, and one thing that you can do if your APP grows bigger and has more traffic, you can add load balancing and high availability using RStudio connect, meaning that you're kind of,
Veerle van Leemput: Get configure RStudio connects to be across multiple servers,
Veerle van Leemput: And then, setting up an external shared file server,
Veerle van Leemput: That kind of then surface to,
Veerle van Leemput: Where all the files are storage for RStudio connect,
Veerle van Leemput: And then you have low solutions with docker obviously,
Veerle van Leemput: what's kind of our cto connect does under the hood docker is something that you didn't do separately to kind of ship your application with this environment to a server,
Veerle van Leemput: Whatever surfing that may be, and then your APP is being run there and, as you can be used for that, as your APP servers but also any other cloud service provider really has the option to do that,
Veerle van Leemput: And then there's also shiny server open source, which is a fully open source solution where you can also,
Veerle van Leemput: which you can add to one of your service if you want and serve your application from there, so there are lots of alternatives, and I can talk for hours about,
Veerle van Leemput: How how you can set that up and how you can do that and going into the technicalities, but it is just to give you a brief overview of what options, there are and that's,
Veerle van Leemput: Our cto connected to one of them,
Veerle van Leemput: So,
Veerle van Leemput: And we've optimized we did not offer my phone yet, but we have deployed your application software so we've written our code and we've made it maintainable we have build a structure,
Veerle van Leemput: We have thought about user experience so we've deployed it somewhere, so now it's time to go look into bit more detail into how we can optimize shiny,
Veerle van Leemput: To kind of make sure that everybody who wants to access the application at a given point in time, can also do so, and the first thing i'm going to talk about,
Veerle van Leemput: which you is process configuration and I quickly touched upon this when I said that we always have five our processes running for our shiny APP before number API,
Veerle van Leemput: Because, as you might know a shiny EP or a plumber API requires in our process, meaning that our needs to be up and running and as needs to be ready to do stuff,
Veerle van Leemput: And you can configure these kinds of settings and these kinds of settings that I mentioned here maximum processes minimum processes, the maximum connections for process,
Veerle van Leemput: load factor, and you can set them in most cases, yourself, so in shiny apps,io which is not an enterprise solution, but if you're still there,
Veerle van Leemput: The settings I will also be dead in RStudio connect and and it's just very important also for if you're deploying your APP in,
Veerle van Leemput: For any other cloud service provider it's important to understand how this works and how you are kind of redirecting your users to an art process,
Veerle van Leemput: Because the shiny advertising our process okay so, then there is an our process and shiny yep and then there's also user,
Veerle van Leemput: So the user can basically help on to that our process, and you can say Okay, I want to have only one user for our process or I want to have multiple, and that is kind of going to determine your scalability of the application,
Veerle van Leemput: So,
Veerle van Leemput: Things that you can tweak, for example, are the maximum number of processes that you are allowing to run for your shiny so,
Veerle van Leemput: If you said it's very high let's say and the maximum number of processes can be 40 50,000 whatever you choose and it also means that it's more resource consuming because the more,
Veerle van Leemput: Our processes, you have running on your server The more that server is going to be occupied with actually maintaining and managing all those are processes so,
Veerle van Leemput: You need to be bit consider with hear about Okay, how many processes Do I really need,
Veerle van Leemput: and am I potentially overloading my server the minimum number of processes is means you have an s in our case, a minimum number of processes running for your shiny so at any point in time, so if you set this higher that say 10 1515,
Veerle van Leemput: It means that you also consume more resources, because all these processes are running they consume,
Veerle van Leemput: memory of your server so the higher you set this, the more recent presuming that will be so you need to think about that, in our case, we chose for five minimum processes, because,
Veerle van Leemput: If we're looking at the number of users, that are coming at the simultaneous time to be at and they're doing stuff This is more than enough,
Veerle van Leemput: But if you have the minimum number of focuses set it means that there's always in our process running for your application, meaning that the startup in time will increase drastically,
Veerle van Leemput: Because and that's kind of the downside of building a shiny APP the our process needs to be startup So besides loading your APP,
Veerle van Leemput: It also needs to load in our session so together that can take a lot of time and people don't like to wait and especially if you are building,
Veerle van Leemput: Apps for for a large audience Apps that people pay for, and you have to have high expectations people can't wait,
Veerle van Leemput: 40 seconds for that APP to load needs to be 10 seconds Max and if there's any loading time at all, then it needs to be some kind of user friendly way of loading with kind of spinners and waiters and whatever,
Veerle van Leemput: But this is really important for us to make sure that our APP is fast also when it's starting up,
Veerle van Leemput: Then you have the maximum connections for process, which means how many users are you letting on to each our process if you set this very low, it means that, for example, in our case, we have said to one,
Veerle van Leemput: there's only one years we're allowed per process, because otherwise users have to wait for each other, because if one user is pushing a button to do a calculation,
Veerle van Leemput: And the other than the certain section is basically occupies and we all know, when our session is occupied, then you yeah you can,
Veerle van Leemput: You kind of can't give an assignment or a calculation, but our won't do anything until the previous one, is executed so,
Veerle van Leemput: we've chosen to set our maximum connects per session per process to one, but it really depends on how your APP is working and,
Veerle van Leemput: What is best for you, but the lower, you said that the less load, there will be birth process, but it will also be more reasons consuming so we constantly see here already, the kind of the decision you need to make between how many resources do I want to invest versus how,
Veerle van Leemput: Dedicated do I want my processes to be,
Veerle van Leemput: The last one is low factor that's a value between zero and one and the lower means that you spin up many new processes so you can also if you have,
Veerle van Leemput: The maximum number of connections proposal set to five, for example, five users can see more things to the access to our session,
Veerle van Leemput: And if you said is very low, it means that as soon as these people start taking buttons and doing calculations and asking things from the our section,
Veerle van Leemput: That they get redirected to another process or that the new process is being spun up to kind of handle that load in our case it doesn't matter because we only have one connection per section,
Veerle van Leemput: But it could mean lot like playing around with the settings can drastically change the performance of your APP and I remember from previous Apps that I deployed using either, I think it was even called RStudio shiny server or something like that, back in the days,
Veerle van Leemput: But,
Veerle van Leemput: You can see changes pretty soon when you are playing around with the settings so keep that in mind,
Veerle van Leemput: So that's one thing that you can optimize, but most of the game really is to be made in the APP itself So how are you going to make your APP false, how are you going to make your EP enjoyable,
Veerle van Leemput: Because that is part of building enterprise grade Apps they need to work great people expect a lot from them,
Veerle van Leemput: So smart coding, and how are we going to speed up our shiny application one way, we can do that is by using cache and cache is an interesting,
Veerle van Leemput: way of kind of reducing the time it takes to get out so imagine that people can hit the burden in your shiny APP and once they hit that button, there will be a very lengthy calculation running,
Veerle van Leemput: I don't know, maybe you have some coffee machine learning model or something, but they choose,
Veerle van Leemput: One input and the calculation runs and it gets an output is obviously a shame if then a second years, who comes in chooses the exact same input, does the calculation again and gets the exact same output again it's kind of a waste of time, why should you do that calculation twice,
Veerle van Leemput: So this is where cache comes in, because what you also can do is say okay well the first user,
Veerle van Leemput: Research request requested a result for this input input, as we call it,
Veerle van Leemput: We do that lengthy calculation, yes, it takes some time before the next one, the next use this we're not going to do, dead,
Veerle van Leemput: No instead we're going to immediately use the results that were being cached from this calculation so caching is basically a way of storing your output,
Veerle van Leemput: Somewhere in this case on your server or whatever you choose to store it,
Veerle van Leemput: And then retrieving it from storage, instead of doing the calculation so, especially if you have a large audience for your APP it can save a lot of time and especially if a large audience is doing, many of the same things,
Veerle van Leemput: And not only if you haven't lived on set and even if you have just one user using your APP but it's constantly switching between input a B, C ABC began see you again,
Veerle van Leemput: it's kind of requesting constantly that same calculation because he's just shifting inputs and he forgets kind of what the outcome of a while so goes back again, and so, even for single users and it can be very beneficial to just store these results,
Veerle van Leemput: There are two ways, you can implement cache in shiny The first is the man was package which kind of helps you to store food options,
Veerle van Leemput: And the result of those functions as cache and you have Chinese buyers cache function,
Veerle van Leemput: I have an example of both of them on my github page and I will share,
Veerle van Leemput: That afterwards,
Veerle van Leemput: So cache sounds nice but a couple of disclaimers and it's obviously only useful when your output does not change, and does not change, often so,
Veerle van Leemput: let's say that your output changes I don't know because there's a random the seeds in there, or whatever it changes every time that there's no point,
Veerle van Leemput: It also is not that much point if your data behind it changes, like every I don't know six hours,
Veerle van Leemput: or every day it only is useful when it doesn't change regularly so it's actually point of storing your own food,
Veerle van Leemput: And then the downside of using cache is that it requires space, because obviously output needs to be stored somewhere and it does require some space,
Veerle van Leemput: And you need to think about sensitive data as well, because if you are kind of sharing your cached results which are other users, you need to think about okay is user a allowed to see whatever user see did you know is that output for them the same is that,
Veerle van Leemput: Something that they vote should be able to access so that's something that you need to think about but cache can be a game changer in the performance of your APP,
Veerle van Leemput: Another smart thing you can do is using background processes and I touched upon this a bit by saying that if you have multiple users per connection,
Veerle van Leemput: that they have to wait for each other, because the session is occupied,
Veerle van Leemput: Well, that sometimes can happen and we don't want that, because we don't want to have parallel execution know we want to have a synchronous execution of code,
Veerle van Leemput: Especially if you're developing an APP for multiple users, you want to them to be able to do things at the same time, and not be affected, and in fact,
Veerle van Leemput: You also don't want a user to have to wait,
Veerle van Leemput: While something is being calculated and that he or she cannot do anything in the APP so let's say a user hits a button to kind of render a graph and then,
Veerle van Leemput: In the background some data has been retrieved from a database and the calculations aren't being done, and then the crops be granted,
Veerle van Leemput: Well, maybe the user doesn't want to wait those I don't know 30 seconds to photograph to show up maybe in between,
Veerle van Leemput: The user wants to look at another table and maybe hit another button for a lighter calculation or another calculation and you don't want people to wait,
Veerle van Leemput: So this is where color comes into play into play, because with color you can spend a background our processes,
Veerle van Leemput: And this is really cool because your shiny I was rolling one our process, and then you can use color to kind of set up an additional our process,
Veerle van Leemput: And do the calculations there then affects the results and put it back into the karen's our process, so this is especially useful if you have queries to databases which take very long time,
Veerle van Leemput: And this is actually the exact same thing that we do with our API, in fact, and our shiny F, because we actually let an other our process, the work do,
Veerle van Leemput: Do the work retrieve data from database and then kind of send the results back and that's similar principle to call her own be here you do it's English shiny APP,
Veerle van Leemput: At the same time, and this is also useful, for example, when you are starting up your application so own startup most often a bunch of data has to be loaded and you want to,
Veerle van Leemput: display graphs and tables and whatever it might be useful if you just say okay i'll just give a little boost and we'll start up all spin up multiple processes for my application,
Veerle van Leemput: And it works really nice color shuts itself down when the process is done and it's just a really nice and clean way to kind of,
Veerle van Leemput: put some extra resources to your shine yep,
Veerle van Leemput: Then, and other thing about the API and,
Veerle van Leemput: How, you can see that, because, as I said, our APP is about retrieving data from the API displaying it and making it available to download,
Veerle van Leemput: So, in our case, it means the Foster our API is the faster, I was shown yet is because, even though we are pulling in I don't know 100,000 lines of,
Veerle van Leemput: data whenever somebody makes a request, we want to happen that to happen and,
Veerle van Leemput: Lead seconds and what we want to avoid is people have to wait even 10 seconds for the data, because one of the selling points over APP is it's super false so for us it's very important that,
Veerle van Leemput: The API as well, so the shiny up can be false and one of the real game changers for our APP and our API was is that we,
Veerle van Leemput: were going to use feather instead of Jason like a plumber API by default no returns Jason, but you can also let it default to other data for months,
Veerle van Leemput: For example, feather and we found that feathers almost two point times two and a half times faster in comparison to Jason and also the file size is being reduced,
Veerle van Leemput: Because we have to send data from the API to the APP and the more data we have to send in terms of size, the longer it's going to take so,
Veerle van Leemput: By implementing feather and sending it over as a as a smaller FEDER fall and it was very it took it saves a lot of time to actually send the file instead of a json file,
Veerle van Leemput: And, in some cases, we were actually able to reduce API response time by as much as 50% and those are massive numbers and we're very happy that we've used feather and you can use feather in any situation,
Veerle van Leemput: So let's say that you are reading in a reading in a file from this, for example, tried to convert it to a feather fall and I read it in as a pedophile,
Veerle van Leemput: And most often you are way faster, even with even faster again like functions, like every for reading a SCI fi and whatever, and this is a really cool way to speed up your shiny application,
Veerle van Leemput: Alright, and so I hope these kind of tips helped you to kind of have some ideas about how you can improve your shiny application and how you can,
Veerle van Leemput: Make your appt foster and how we did it, and so this was kind of the stuff that I wanted to talk about when it comes to coding,
Veerle van Leemput: Now I want to talk a bit about,
Veerle van Leemput: Testing because it's obviously very important that if you have an APP for,
Veerle van Leemput: Like users enterprise users customers who are relying on a daily basis, on the information that you have in the application you obviously want to test it you want to test to make sure that it can handle the load that you're giving it and you want to be able to test,
Veerle van Leemput: If it's working as expected anyway so don't show up every morning, do you know if it's running or do you have to check yourself how can you be sure that at any point in time, your APP does what it is supposed to do,
Veerle van Leemput: So first we're going to take a look at the first question asked and it's your APP ready for the load that it's supposed to handle, so we need to test for load,
Veerle van Leemput: Testing for load, we can do with a package called shiny load test and shiny load test provides the command line tool called shiny cannon and because I find find shiny cannon a lot cooler than showing load test, I put that as soon as the headline,
Veerle van Leemput: And this basically can also the question for you how many users can your shiny support and,
Veerle van Leemput: it's really cool because the only thing that you need to do is record your our session like your normal user,
Veerle van Leemput: And, and then you kind of let's shiny load test simulate all those recordings and replayed them in parallel, meaning that it can kind of,
Veerle van Leemput: simulate the situation in which multiple users, at the same time, are going to access your APP and then after that you can analyze the results,
Veerle van Leemput: Show low dose has a bunch of convenience functions in there that allow you to analyze all the files that are generates and then you can build nice looking reports and these reports can, for example, tell you the time it takes to load the html page or the time it takes to take,
Veerle van Leemput: to grab your CSS or javascript files or the starting time of the session so how long it actually takes before shiny connects to something js,
Veerle van Leemput: And also calculation time of, for example, and button that you press or any graph that you try to run their table that you're going to display and you also get,
Veerle van Leemput: A lot of details about individual events,
Veerle van Leemput: And a bunch of information is here, and this makes sure that you know,
Veerle van Leemput: Okay, my APP can safely handle this load and then you need to see okay does that actually fit my expectation of how many people are going to visit the APP or Do I need to change something,
Veerle van Leemput: And it's also great to find out what is taking the most time or where you can get some efficiency gains,
Veerle van Leemput: So we just for load another thing that we wanted desk his desk for outcome,
Veerle van Leemput: And testing for outcome, means that we want to be sure that when somebody pushes a button and that the outcome is what we expected every contest for outcome with the package called shiny test do is actually the follow up of the package called shine that's no surprise there,
Veerle van Leemput: And this baggage, you can use to create and run automated best and behind the hood is user steps that's so what you kind of do here in this package is also you record, just like shiny Lotus you record the session,
Veerle van Leemput: And then you kind of replay it both in this case, Shiny still will translate your actions into actual code that's really cool it's like magic, but it will rise actual actual unit tests for you, using test that,
Veerle van Leemput: So this allows you then to kind of everybody talks about our units that are a pain and it takes a lot of fact for that so much time and don't have time to write them and always forget if this makes it super easy,
Veerle van Leemput: I mean it doesn't get easier to that you just play around to the APP you click a few things and the codes there for you,
Veerle van Leemput: And this package is is grow modes to launch a chrome browser a headless one,
Veerle van Leemput: And it's a really cool way to kind of make sure that your APP is doing what it's supposed to do, plus what the thing that's up to you and it's your responsibility,
Veerle van Leemput: Is you need to update those tests whenever you are making a deployment or whatsoever if you don't update your tests and then it's pretty useless,
Veerle van Leemput: But it's a nice way to be confidence about releasing your application within update because, unfortunately, when you change and we all know that when you change somewhere,
Veerle van Leemput: In one part of yet another thing my break and this kind of prevents that, so this is really key to make sure that you don't ship anything to production and George read good,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah so i'm moving on to the last part I want to tell you something about how to monitor performance and APP usage because,
Veerle van Leemput: we've walked through the whole pipeline now from like designing ux designing to code to optimizing shiny to deploying it,
Veerle van Leemput: To testing your application like very high level, but then there's also the thing about Okay, how are you going to monitor your APP and how are you going to know how many people are actually using your APP,
Veerle van Leemput: And how we do that, so how we do, that is, with something i'm still very proud of every day and our status reports we have created status reports with blah stolen and RStudio connect, meaning that every morning,
Veerle van Leemput: or whenever we wish we get a status report in our mailbox like this looking like this, and I even check in on my phone it's like awesome and it just tells me exactly okay,
Veerle van Leemput: This is all good or, this is not good or pay attention to this, these Apps are running these URLs are accessible is the state to suffer services,
Veerle van Leemput: And while there's a bunch of stuff here that isn't necessarily related to shiny but more about our servers, it is important for us to know our service up and running,
Veerle van Leemput: Because our Apps renaldo serves and,
Veerle van Leemput: We want to make sure that, like every morning, everything is running as intended, so what we kind of do every day is we check the disk space, because unfortunately it happens, wants to work and,
Veerle van Leemput: i'm sure i'm not the only one that the disk space was used 100% and what happens then yeah, then you serve her won't it won't do anything anymore, so your APP,
Veerle van Leemput: is not working, but has no school and also things like is the engines country figuration on RD URLs accessible and stuff like that it's a great way to kind of monitor what's going on into your pipeline into your infrastructure,
Veerle van Leemput: And it's just nice to get it as an email so that you're always today,
Veerle van Leemput: And I want to come back to shine cannon because chicken is not only useful for building a nice load tests and kind of seeing you how many users your shiny up can support,
Veerle van Leemput: But it's also a great way to kind of check if your APP is still behaving the same as yesterday,
Veerle van Leemput: Because which shiny cannon or shiny loads this you record it something a recording of you kind of replaying the APP and with the command line tool,
Veerle van Leemput: So shine you can run you can run this as a single recording so you can use shine you can have to do these load test with a member of workers and the low duration and kind of simulating 50 users at same time,
Veerle van Leemput: But you can also use it to say okay i've recording here play it and then give me the results, and is it the same as expected, then yes thumbs up,
Veerle van Leemput: If not give a warning in our case, in one of her states reports, so this is also a great way to kind of ultimately check if your APP is actually running and doing what are they supposed to do,
Veerle van Leemput: And then, a little bit about usage, you need to make sure if you're if you're building your application for your customers, you need to make sure if they're actually using it and how much,
Veerle van Leemput: What we did obviously it's very shiny way to do that we build our own APP which we call the console up,
Veerle van Leemput: And Nichols all we can do a bunch of things, and one of those things is checking usage of our Apps mean that we can see how many times people logged in who did login and how long were therefore,
Veerle van Leemput: What did they do, etc, it allows us to build us a better product, but it also allows us to kind of check in with customers like is everything so Okay, can I help you with something that kind of stuff so,
Veerle van Leemput: Like even though we're a startup we invested a good amount of time into building these kind of tools, because it's very important for us to have insight into usage and insight into what's happening,
Veerle van Leemput: Like in our daily operations and in a very quick note about that you can also do this with our so you connect will be very familiar to to Rachel I think,
Veerle van Leemput: You can use the API for most of you connect if you're using connect to deploy your Apps and you can get all these kinds of stats as well,
Veerle van Leemput: super easy to see who did logging in who interact with your content which content is being viewed most,
Veerle van Leemput: at which time,
Veerle van Leemput: of day and,
Veerle van Leemput: In which we cetera so very important if you're building Apps for,
Veerle van Leemput: enterprise level,
Veerle van Leemput: And then I want to have closing notes with can you build enterprise grade Apps with shiny yes, you definitely can, and I hope that's,
Veerle van Leemput: Today I showed you a little bit of how we manage things and I hope I gave you some tips and tricks to make enterprise grade Apps or to optimize your existing Apps or just,
Veerle van Leemput: Learn you some some some general stuff about shine,
Veerle van Leemput: I don't know that it's time for questions,
Veerle van Leemput: amazing I think there are there are some,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): There are lots of questions Thank you so much beulah I always like to say we're all clapping he can't hear us, we can use our mode you,
Veerle van Leemput: Thank you, thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I will cut this part out of their courting, but I do just want to say for anyone who is here, I want to personally apologize,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But thank you all so much for the great questions to I see there's one that was voted that is what's the benefit of using pins rather than pulling the data from your database and azure,
Veerle van Leemput: Well, what we sometimes found,
Veerle van Leemput: Is that things are actually quicker than doing it in our database, so we use begins to kind of store information that's subsided, and while,
Veerle van Leemput: You obviously can retrieve subset of information database a database needs to run a query needs to find the correct subset can take couple of seconds, and if the bin already contains all the information you need pre processed,
Veerle van Leemput: Whatever it's much quicker to do that, besides that the the data comes in the correct format already so whether you stored it with like,
Veerle van Leemput: As a data table or as a table and with kind of the column formatting you want to this column needs to be an idea of this call needs to be checked or whatever that's all preserved so it's like a really clean way to in an our way,
Veerle van Leemput: quickly retrieve information and it's obviously only does work for subset that are processed data,
Veerle van Leemput: But we found this very, very beneficial,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Some Thank you and, just a quick note i'm not going to allow people to unmute today and ask questions which really stinks I love to be able to have you all ask your own questions I just don't trust it right now,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So if you do want to ask questions you can use the slide Oh, and so it's just i'll put the link in the chat or Jacqueline or lauren if you can share,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But it's just R s T d,io slash meetup dash questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But another one was from Marcus Viola, are there package license considerations, you had to think about when monetizing shiny applications,
Veerle van Leemput: Yes, definitely not all our packages are available for free and you need to have a license think about high charter for example that's a requires an enterprise license,
Veerle van Leemput: You need to be aware of that yep definitely,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay, thank you, someone else do you find rhino more easy to handle reactive so, for example, passing them between modules than gone,
Veerle van Leemput: hmm interesting questions and I have to say, because it's a super new package I didn't have time to go fully into it, yet I just kind of played around with the toy example, so I,
Veerle van Leemput: can't really answer that question at this point in time, I hope it will be easier because I do see some advantages of using box,
Veerle van Leemput: For modules compared to shiny modules because they just work very differently,
Veerle van Leemput: So yeah i'm very curious do to export it myself do,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome i'm going to copy the questions over from slide out to the chat to just so we have the timestamp of them when we go back to the recording, but do you use promises to scale the application,
Veerle van Leemput: And no we didn't use promises, but we are using color and stats because promises,
Veerle van Leemput: Still wasn't providing us with with the good solution to do whatever we want them we find color more easy to use and also more clean it cleans itself up pretty easily while, sometimes with promises some stuff lingers around to keep keep lingering around,
Veerle van Leemput: And we didn't find those issues with color so that's why we use that instead, but it works, the same as a promise that color is nothing more,
Veerle van Leemput: or less, except for a couple of benefits or maybe disadvantages compared to promises so yeah,
Veerle van Leemput: hope that on Tuesday,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay, thank you, sorry i'm just firing this away for free now,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Someone else, I was interested in in rhino and said for beginners was shiny would you recommend golem or rhino,
Veerle van Leemput: Oh that's a good question um,
Veerle van Leemput: I know for beginners i'm actually tempted to say rhino and I don't know why, but I do have a feeling that,
Veerle van Leemput: is especially with the documentation they provided it could be really a cool way to set up your project and, for me, when I was looking at Ryan, which felt more,
Veerle van Leemput: intuitively into typically compared to golden like if you have built our packages before then, I definitely think golden would be like a good first step, because it sounds very familiar to you,
Veerle van Leemput: But if you don't have experience with baggage building maybe I would say pick rhino and see what you can make it a little disclaimer rhino is still like super new and in development so also the developer say that might be some glitches here and there, obviously teething issues so,
Veerle van Leemput: that's just a little disclaimer but yeah I would maybe say rhino,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I some another question that's just being uploaded right now, from David is the myth is that only Python can be used for production great Apps what made you choose to use our was it shiny,
Veerle van Leemput: hmm and,
Veerle van Leemput: I chose are like in university it back as data scientists I learned to programming languages are,
Veerle van Leemput: advice and, obviously, and I stuck with our because we, I was mainly active in the pharmaceutical industry and our is they're just,
Veerle van Leemput: it's more preferred about fighting, probably because it's from where it's coming from I think definitely amid that only apply to can be used for prediction great Apps,
Veerle van Leemput: Look, the language doesn't really matter,
Veerle van Leemput: As I said, we build a plumber API using our which is just are we build an outstanding API does is being used in prediction pipelines for other companies, right now, and nobody knows and nobody really cares,
Veerle van Leemput: What people care about is okay an API needs to be quick needs to be delivered what what I wanted to do lightning the data,
Veerle van Leemput: and whatever it's written in our Python javascript node they don't really care it just needs to be,
Veerle van Leemput: Up to standards, and you can achieve that with ours well and obviously it's Nice that because I knew our that there were shiny so it wasn't like,
Veerle van Leemput: The step was was more easy to make to build a shiny application I learned a few and note like later on in my career after shiny, but I must say this still, even though I have seen few a note, I still,
Veerle van Leemput: we're still using shiny for enterprise grade enterprise grade Apps just because,
Veerle van Leemput: There is a fast development it's false to develop extra features for the APP,
Veerle van Leemput: And the performance is just really good as long as you know how to use it and how to design it and that's why I said at the beginning,
Veerle van Leemput: Some people said to me your APP doesn't look like a shiny up yeah but like we build an APP how we build it should be irrelevant and we did that with Chinese so yeah definitely meant that i'm i'm ready to burst,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I love it,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Someone else asked is strictly better than using json or what are the drawbacks,
Veerle van Leemput: It is strictly better about I,
Veerle van Leemput: kind of don't think you can always say it's 100% better in some use cases i'm sure it'll be better than the other,
Veerle van Leemput: For one thing, feather not everybody knows how to deal with that so in our API as well we've given our users to option which output format, do you want to have returned to you want to have Jason or do you want to have feather because,
Veerle van Leemput: If our clients, it also depends on there, and can they read in feather files do they have tools with that,
Veerle van Leemput: And are they comfortable working with it, etc, but it doesn't really,
Veerle van Leemput: it's not really different it's just data that you are transfer me a transforming she's transferring it's just data that you are transferring and and then you need to unpack it and we've seen like especially file size reduction and speed reading and then and, in our case, that was better,
Veerle van Leemput: So yeah,
Veerle van Leemput: that's, all I can say about it,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I know we originally scheduled to 15 minutes past the hour, so I want to see if you have time for a few more questions,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay awesome there is a great question, I see that came in on slide oh was where do you see the line between bi and shiny for your use cases what positives and or limitations, would you say about both,
Veerle van Leemput: So, just to clarify what men would be I like tools like Bobby is,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Yes, i'm assuming like business intelligence tools like tablo and power bi,
Veerle van Leemput: and
Veerle van Leemput: Luke if you want to build a simple standard dashboard with standard graphs and tables Why not use by the if you have access to this tool and your team kind of knows it,
Veerle van Leemput: But as soon as you want to do custom things you want to have a special graph you want to have special functionality, I mean we wanted to have a favorite that,
Veerle van Leemput: So that people could actually select their favorite products and then that was being stored it's being stored in the database and then,
Veerle van Leemput: The pickers kind of they can make a choice, do you want to see on your favorites but you won't see everything, how are you going to do that in power bi and obviously,
Veerle van Leemput: If you want, you can do everything properly, but then for this level of customization I would say shiny so as soon as you,
Veerle van Leemput: are looking at more customized features building things your own way, especially if you know how to leverage shiny with custom javascript and and stuff then sky's the limit and I would not choose for a standards,
Veerle van Leemput: In my eyes, a standard rbi dashboard,
Veerle van Leemput: And it's like because it's a web APP shiny is a web APP people can access it from wherever they are, whether they have access to Bobby I yes or not so it's that's huge and like positives and limitations,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah I think I covered that,
Veerle van Leemput: yep,
awesome,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): One other question was any,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): tips advice or resources for enterprise grade ui development so interested to hear how you make an APP look less like a shiny up,
Veerle van Leemput: and
Veerle van Leemput: yeah good question and, like we have ux designers who occasionally design stuff for us, and then we just build it and what we did in some occasions was building html stills ourselves so with the html which is package we build an own widgets that kind of was a,
Veerle van Leemput: Multi page form, so we kind of we kind of built if there's another user interface components available in in anything Open Source we just build it ourselves, but,
Veerle van Leemput: One package that greatly helps to instantly make your absolute better in split seconds before that, before that is awesome it's a bootstrap base package,
Veerle van Leemput: And B is for desk basically during sure at within a matter of seconds into a good looking APP already and then obviously you need to take care of like placement of stuff how you're going to display your graphs etc,
Veerle van Leemput: But vs Pradesh and already gives you like the basic layout for a great APP including like these little nice tools that you want to have like dark mode like mode interactive components of sidebar that's kind of,
Veerle van Leemput: goes away nice me etc maximizing full screen mobile friendly so yeah definitely add that,
Veerle van Leemput: Before,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): We shouldn't be doing ball think about in the chat to,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay, let me just see i'll go through, just a few more questions here but someone asked anonymously, have you found a practical upper limit for users of a shiny up above which performance suffers So is there, like a certain number of users you've seen,
Veerle van Leemput: I don't think i've seen it like,
Veerle van Leemput: Practically and,
Veerle van Leemput: We have like I think 70 users, but there are never accessing,
Veerle van Leemput: The content that the same time,
Veerle van Leemput: So I didn't experience those settings and but I actually can kind of calculate how much we can handle because we have one server, which is RStudio connects,
Veerle van Leemput: And because we only allow one connection per session and I kind of can calculate how many sessions, we can actually have, and I think the kind of amount of simultaneous sessions, we can have with like 50 or something,
Veerle van Leemput: And we have five running for each of our main Apps so five for the API from the cloud data for the analytics of 15,
Veerle van Leemput: So we have still an abundance of sessions that still can be used as spun up without running into problems, and if you do run into problems it's not like something breaks or explodes now your user just gets a friendly come back later we're overloaded message,
Veerle van Leemput: So even that is not the end of the world, you want to prevent it, but yeah,
Veerle van Leemput: But it really depends on what machinery you put behind it, the bigger your machines, the more servers yeah the more it's,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome I just shared one in the chat which are originally just came to mind,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): If the California state coma dashboard I know, had thousands of users, it was open to millions of citizens so there's a blog posts on that one too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay, let me go back over,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Vikram asked you recommended cacheing,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Your pins to speed up Apps,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Using data that doesn't change often any tips for more dynamic data,
Veerle van Leemput: So dynamic data,
Veerle van Leemput: Well, maybe one tip I can give you if you're talking about the navigation you're also pulling from a database,
Veerle van Leemput: Like, especially since we're a startup company we basically just started somewhere, you know, we had a database, which was fine,
Veerle van Leemput: As soon as we started looking into optimizing the database as well and changing number of course changing availability dare,
Veerle van Leemput: Massive gains and so, if you can pull data from a database in your database foster an organized well because organization matters and where do you put your indexes how are you going to make sure that they don't can easily be retrieved and then I would definitely look into depth,
Veerle van Leemput: it's just whenever you're developing an APP and you need to pull in data, you always have to ask yourself Do I really need everything of this data and if not, can I make it smaller and where does this data come from and can I make wherever it came from foster yes or no,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So yeah Thank you so let's see time for two more questions and if there's anything else that we missed if it's Okay, if I send them over to you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Maybe we can get them through email okay cool,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I see Leonard just asked thanks for a great presentation and meetup if you have time was wondering if you have shiny cannon installed on the development machine or on a server,
Veerle van Leemput: So we have it installed on or Linux,
Veerle van Leemput: ubuntu server,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah,
Veerle van Leemput: Great so instead of development machine belt yeah we have two servers one development server one production server,
Veerle van Leemput: I think this one was installed on our development Linux server yep,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): cool Thank you and then I see Mara ass,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I want to know if you could share some of the script testing and the shiny project and the presentation, but also, and thank you for this webinar,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): don't know barely have you able to share this with the recording,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah well I have actually here,
Veerle van Leemput: This is my thing,
Veerle van Leemput: let's say socialize,
Veerle van Leemput: Go find me on linkedin I have here a bunch of resources of the things that I mentioned i'm not sure if you mentioned, if that answered your question and I can also share my gifts of user name in the chat or Rachel can do that,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah I can actually I can check can adjust but i'm i'm host I can,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You can as Co host yep,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah, so this is my my github username and I have a couple of guests on there and open projects which will go over some of these topics, for example, there are examples with call or dare there are examples with shiny option there,
Veerle van Leemput: With using tables etc there's probably you can find some code there,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome yeah i'll share these slides and then the links to all the resources with the recording which will put up on YouTube and then i'll share it on linkedin and Twitter or wherever I posted this meetup as well,
Veerle van Leemput: yeah perfectly fine,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome I just want to say thank you so much for Veerle for an amazing presentation, I see a ton of great feedback coming through on slide oh two because we're not using the chat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But a bunch of people saying, this has been an excellent presentation and really appreciate it,
Veerle van Leemput: Oh, thank you it's really nice to hear that Thank you all for joining and,
Veerle van Leemput: let's stay in touch if you have any questions you can reach out here to Rachel and yeah Thank you thanks for the invite,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah definitely Thank you so much, have a great rest of the day, everybody,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Everyone,
Veerle van Leemput: You bye bye,